Are you looking for a show that has Nazi puppets cockroaches making out with rats and ravenous attacking buttholes
Look no further than Doom Patrol
But did I never mention the sentient?
Teleporting gender queer Street Vic and I hung out on while Jane lost her shit and tried to get married. Yes
We can't forget that teleporting gender queer Street. Doom Patrol is an absolutely fantastic show
Which may have some of the best character arcs of any comic adaptation to date?
So in this video
I'll be breaking down the ending and taking a deep dive into how our characters went from zeroes to heroes.
The last episode entitled Ezekiel Patrol named after the cockroach who believes he's God's
Messenger follows our heroes after the big revelation in episode 14 that Niles Caulder
Their beloved chief was responsible for all the tragic events that changed the course of their lives forever.
For a show about superheroes most of the plot actually revolves around the characters overcoming their past and coming to terms with their new
Identities. We have Larry Trainor a gay US Air Force pilot who gets fused with a space anomaly and shuns his friends and family
Rita Farr a washed-up Hollywood actress who can turn into a hideous blob
Cliff Steele a philandering ex racecar driver turned Iron Man
Victor aka Cyborg a half man half cyborg struggling with the death of his mother of which he feels responsible for and
Crazy Jane a young woman unable to control her 64 multiple
Personalities if these characters are gonna become a team and defeat the show's main villain. Mr. Nobody
They'll need to first overcome their weaknesses and grow as characters
but back to the plot the beginning of the final episode starts with the team confronting Niles about the shocking revelation that he
engineered their tragedies
for example
He was the one who set up Larry to get hit by the space anomaly and
was also the one that set up Cliffs car Crash, which killed his wife and subsequently turned him into a robot
Needless to say the entire team is pissed and want nothing to do with him.
It's tragically ironic that the whole season surrounds them trying to save Niles only for them to shun him in the end.
Mr. Nobody doesn't kill them. That's not his goal
He wants revenge and what better way than for all these heroes who are immortal to live eternity wallowing in their own self-pity
hating themselves and living in misery we get
A brief glimpse of what all their lives are like in this hell on earth Rita is an undervalued high school drama teacher
Jane is a junkie Cyborg suffers from nightmares and Niles lives alone at Doom Manor in essence
The Doom Patrol is doomed to live out the rest of their lives as miserable
Nobodies the fact they have to live this out forever makes it doubly tragic
But that's what this first season of Doom Patrol is all about immortality
in the final episode we learn that Niles was part of a program at the Bureau of Normalcy called the Immortus initiative
on the surface It looks like he just wants to find a way to be immortal like his lover
Oye WA but the real reason is for him to live longer enough to make sure his daughter is protcected.
to understand this we need to go back to episode 10 and examine Niles Relationship with Oye WA
the mystical Huntress who saved his life in the northern Yukon. This happened all the way back in 1913
when Niles and his partner Alastair working then for the Bureau of oddities were attacked by wolves
Niles survives and is rescued by Oye WA who becomes his captor and later his lover he finds out that she's immortal and
becomes fascinated with her staying by her side and beginning their love affair
It's only when Alastair finds Niles years later that he must leave her in order to protect her if you were to stay he would risk
the bureau of Normalcy finding and capturing her, but now we know a little bit more
Oye WA had his child which will later come to know as Dorothy Spinner
But we'll get to that in a bit
Niles locked Dorothy in the dollhouse on Danny Street to keep her safe from the bureau and Mr. Nobody
and devoted his life to finding a way to become immortal Jane, Cliff, Larry, Rita and Cyborg all became his experiments
his way to find a path to immortality. But as we'll find out these experiments fail
These characters are all broken both internally and externally
Jane can't control her personalities, Larry his negative man,
Rita Her blob powers cyborg his grid system and
Cliff Well Cliffs a robot Niles made them this way and deep down feels responsible for them
Hence why he allows them to stay at Doom Manor and gives them purpose through the Doom Patrol, but you think
Mr. Nobody now victorious would be celebrating his victory. Nope
He achieved all he had hoped for but now his drunken himself into a stupor. He no longer has a purpose. He's directionless
He's back to being a nobody what's a villain to do?
That's when he's introduced to Ezekiel the cockroach who tells him he hasn't finished off Niles for good if you really want revenge on him
You must take away. The one thing he truly cares about his daughter at the same time our miserable
Doom Patrol is haunted by Chumbawamba's I get knocked down and I get up again a fitting song for our ragtag group of zeros
They've been knocked down and if they're gonna get back up again
They'll need to put their hatred of Niles aside and band together as a team. The song leads them to Doom Manor,
Where a distraught Niles informs them that
Mr. Nobody has trapped his daughter and Danny the street inside a painting and he needs their help to save them
It's here that Cliff is like no effing way after all Niles
Orchestrated the death of his wife so that he could use cliff as his next experiment. It's pretty messed up
But Jane is the one to agree saying she's not doing it for Niles
But for Danny and the girl and it makes sense that Jane is the one to say this. Her whole Multiple Personality Disorder
was brought upon as a child who wasn't protected her personalities act as a shield protecting her from her abusive father
I'm sure in some way Jane feels this need to be there for a young child
Because no one was ever there for her. The Doom Patrol
transports into the painting only to find out that the cockroach and Admiral whiskers have ballooned into giant kaiju like creatures
if they're gonna put a stop to them, Mr. Nobody and save Niles his daughter. They'll need a plan it's--at peeping toms perpetual cabaret.
We learned that Mr. Nobody has been overthrown by Ezekiel and that he used the beard hunters powers to track down Niles´s daughter
He drinks himself silly, but it's Rita who gives him a pep talk.
She says it's better to be a nobody than nothing and convinces him to have a comeback and use his power of narration
to convince Ezekiel to make out with Admiral whiskers. Yes. This plan is absolutely bonkers
but so is the show. Rita, cyborg and cliff make their way into the Cockroaches stomach
while Larry uses his negative man energy to open a portal back to the real world. In the dollhouse Jane and Niles rescue Dorathy
when Larry transports all them back to the real world leaving the beard hunter and Mr.Nobody
in the white space. The white space referring to the white space found in between comic book panels since cockroaches can survive
Powerful blasts of radiation Rita, cyborg and cliff are able to withstand the blast so can Larry because he is radioactive himself
But how did Niles Dorothy and Jane magically transport into the stomach of the cockroach?
The answer may have something to do with Dorothy and her special powers.
In the comics Dorothy spinner is a character who has the ability to bring imaginary beings to life,
She also has a facial deformity that gives her the appearance of an ape.
This could also be why we never actually see her face in the final episode.
Her name is a nod to Dorothy Gale from The Wizard of Oz and she even wears the same clothing in pigtails Dorothy does at the very end.
The ape-like face would also work with her mother being an ancient hairy godlike woman,
But unlike the comics it appears this Dorothy spinner has far greater powers. When Mr. Nobody is confronted by Niles
he says that the girl is quote an Adorable chip off the old block and that she was the woman who enlarged Ezekiel and Admiral whiskers.
In episode 10 we also see that when the beard hunter found Dorothy. He was attacked by the same monster
Oye WA was someone more than a century earlier? So it's likely whatever powers Oye WA had,
had been transferred to the daughter in the comics Dorothy later becomes a member of the Doom Patrol
And this might happen in the show as well.
It will be interesting to see if season two will pick up right after the events of season one or a few years later when
Dorothy is older and better able to harness her powers. This leaves us with what is next for Doom Patrol
Will they remain together or go back to their separate ways?
Yes, they did save Dorothy, but will their hatred for Niles keep them apart. My guess is that with Mr. Nobody still in the picture.
Pardon the pun, something will bring our Patrol back together.
This show was a totally fun ride and the best DC comic adaptation. I've seen yet and here's hoping for a season two.
Thanks for watching everyone. Please make sure to LIKE and subscribe and give me your thoughts on the season below
You can also follow me on Twitter @ThinkstoryYT. I'll be coming out with more videos
So stay tuned and remember daddy loves you very much.